[music]
Okay. So, thank you very much for uh for
coming and thanks for the organizer of
Machina 2026 for the invitation. So,
I'll be speaking about uh well the title
of my presentation is a bit uh say
controversy but uh yeah I didn't find
better to say whether humanoids are
ready for the job. Okay. So it's the
question I can give you the answer
quickly right away. It's no. Okay. And
probably you will I will try to argue
why and what is missing. Could you bring
this technology into the to the stage?
So I think that the turn on human robots
started basically after the uh disaster
of Fukushima. So uh uh in fact uh Japan
was under shock and uh the question and
the society as well because the people
couldn't understand why Japan who were
leading basically robotics and human
robotics at that time was not able to
provide a solution for having what
researchers used to write in the papers
were meeting robots to send them into
hazardous environments and to
environments where it's dangerous for
people to go. But at the end, okay, we
end up sending these white guys, okay,
to to do the job, the dirty job. And
most of them, of course, was a bit old
because uh they didn't take young people
for the reason of high radiation, as you
you might guess. So the other point,
okay, of uh a disaster, let's say, now
uh this is the uh forecast of what is
the scenario for the growth of the
population in Europe. Okay, I I better
not show you the one in Japan because
then it's really more alarming than this
one with three like scenarios like in
terms of immigrants. Okay, whether we
keep the statu or we have four time of
the statu and two times of the statu and
this curve speaks by itself about the
problem that are facing most of the
major industries uh even in France okay
that they are difficulties to hire
people okay in some particular tasks.
So um are you one who's ready for the
job? What jobs? From my experience more
long years working on on this field as a
researcher uh I see three main okay
applications or possible applications
for this. So large scale manufacturing
uh human assistance and also the defense
and security for uh this um my opinion
okay this is just my opinion is that if
you have to put money now especially for
countries like France it's better to put
it on manufacturing because
manufacturing will major the technology
uh will solve a lot of problems that you
might have as a gap between bringing
that kind of technologies to the
assistive okay and the social which is
about 30% of the GDP in France or to the
military in terms of theization which is
about 2% of the GDP. So um if I was like
a stakeholder and if I was a government
I would put a lot of money on
manufacturing and this robot
manufacturing to promote first okay
solving a lot of hard problems and
industry could put money for that. Um
this is um so a few experience of what
we have done so far. This was in 2019.
Okay. Uh where we gathered the team
around uh um one of the first deployment
of human as a as a as a proof of concept
if you want and uh it was with Airbus.
Okay. So Airbus was looking for
automating their manufacturing. Okay.
And they didn't find a solution for
obvious reason. You cannot have fixed
robot as you have in car industries and
uh so the robot has to go into all the
three floors and do a myriad of tasks at
that time. Uh Pabris V I'm not sure
whether he's here or not. Okay, he's
there. He was part of the team and he
was responsible for the working okay for
the working expertise that you have. So
the guy is sitting right there and uh so
at that time we were really okay the the
the main thing was to gather the best of
the technologies we have in terms of
control contact planning visual
surveying um like um perception slam and
we gathered all this to try to see
whether we can have one use case in
Airbus okay going into the floor etc.
But you see when Honda for instance saw
this demo okay they they confessed that
they were not able to replicate it.
Okay, at that time Honda was in the top
for for IMO and we were looking uh into
of course people who can help okay to
design this robot because at the end of
the project if Pabris remember Airbus
was saying okay we are happy with this
it was in 2019 but who will provide this
robot okay because we are not able to do
it ourself we don't want to do it so uh
and the lesson I get from this first was
that if you have a good technology if
you are too early it's not good and if
you are too late it's not good as well
so you need to have the timing in terms
of innovation. This was followed by
Mishla. Okay. Also a big company as you
say tire company in France. They gave us
also a use case where you have to roll
this mobile around in the factory and
then mount it in what they call this
unwinder machines. Okay. And you see all
these demos were extremely complex to
realize and we had at that time only
prototype humanoids. Okay. We didn't
have like the humanoid with high
technology that we have now. And still
we were this one was about not just
walking and go to the place and do
something but it was also about walking
and doing so local manipulation
basically with human robots. This bins
uh weighs a lot around like 100 kg okay
each and the robot has to locate itself
in the factory and then go and
manipulate these things okay all
together.
So with Honda, Honda have only B2C.
Okay. The philosophy of Honda is we do a
product for consumers. They don't they
don't want to do business to business.
So they they told me, okay, if you want
to work together, we want to have robots
that really help people to stand up. And
this is also a first. We did it like
last year we finished the project and it
was about how can we make robots to help
people to stand chair and the idea is to
bring these people at houses. The
problem is uh what I said to Honda is
really that um it's not a matter of
technology here. You have to build the
whole environment. Okay. The liability,
the insurance, uh the whole story that
is beyond your control basically. So you
have to accompany this. But even if you
have this solution readily available in
a box, okay, you can deliver it to the
people, the people will not be able to
to deploy it really at houses because
you have to build also the whole
ecosystem, okay, around it. And uh so I
told them you better wait also that the
technology is maturing in manufacturing.
So they want to do that. Now they told
me okay we can do things but we do it
B2B inside Honda. Basically they will do
a B2B first inside Honda and then okay
they will see if we can deploy it uh
this all these demos have been done with
this software which is open. It's
basically the gathering of all the
knowledge we have uh since long. Okay.
And it is free to upload. We don't
control only human widths. control any
kind of things as far as you have the
URDF model of your robot. Okay, you can
reproduce part of these things.
So I wanted to come back to uh to
aircraft because uh there is a common
thing with all these applications. Okay,
the people have really worked hard to
design what they call what are the
non-added value for the for the workers
or even for the nurses or even for
whatsoever. So I think the good starting
point is to go about what are the
non-added value tasks so that you really
work [clears throat] on automating this.
It was easy also for industry and the
other reason for why it's good for
industry because they have CAD models
for basically everything. They know what
they are manipulating. They have strict
rules. Okay, even for the workers when
it's much more easy to deploy the
technology first in manufacturing to
major it and after to consider other
aspects. Um so what I have learned okay
from all this is um that the good
software and the would not compensate
for uh for a poor mechanical design.
Many of the things that we did was not
good and the people also the workers in
Honda mission say oh why your robot
cannot do this why your robot cannot do
that and and each of the time is the
robot was lacking the degrees of
freedom. Okay. Uh because most of the
the right use cases for humanit is
really to work in cumbersome
environments and when you need to enter
a product and get out of the product.
Okay. If if like if you take the
[clears throat] car manufacturing for
instance you have uh the cars even if
they are fixed or not okay the robot
will work outside basically the product.
But if you need a technology that goes
inside your product, get out of your
product that needs mobility and then in
this case humanit are generally the best
solution you might have even for for
cars. I have seen a lot of demos on
YouTube for cars BMW Mercedes. But you
see I think all the people are say
always the same thing but taking this
object putting it there is okay. You can
just put the wheels okay you put two
arms on the wheels and it does the job.
It's flat. You don't have stairs. You
don't have things that to that you have
to bypass. So the the optimal solution
will be rather this than okay a human
robot uh with legs. But in any case if
you need to work in cumbersome
environment you have to design your
architecture so that you are able to
reproduce the the motion inside the
human space because most of the cases
like in air bus etc. uh you you when you
enter this environment if you don't have
the right degree of freedom or if you
don't have the right kinematics you end
up touching and colliding everything
basically and then the system is not
able okay to move in the way the human
moves
um so this is uh what he's showing
another one I learned is uh of course
that uh now you have a lot of knowledge
in terms of robustness in walking okay
through thanks to a
problem for this is that in industry you
cannot go with your blackbox neur
network and say okay just put is on your
robot and that it's okay if your robot
do a mistake from time to time. This
doesn't go to work. It's not going to
work. Okay, you need to you need
certifications, you need explanability
of whatever you have to develop and
whatever you develop. So, we have taken
another route from what is the trend
now. So, I don't have time to go into it
but uh at least that is for the local
manipulation like a tremendous advances
thanks to RIL and AI for but in robotics
the control has never been the problem.
Okay, the problem has always been the
perception. Okay, and in fact my advice
is to use datadriven approaches and
blackbox policies in parimony. Okay,
when you when you want to do this uh on
the robot because okay they you need to
have this part of certification
explanability and it's better to say
that you know the whole thing is
something that I know how to explain but
there is some few parts that are data
driven so the controller can be aware of
okay I I know that this part is not
something I can rely on 100% so I can
prepare like strategies to recover for
that um so slam now is kind of a major
technology so there's a lot of advanc
classes I don't like uh I don't
recommend industries to put money on
that there is big groups already working
on this it will be mature and you can be
using it even with the semantics which
we didn't have at that time it mean the
slam that can understand what's around
the environment and locate the robot
very nicely um so the execution
performance is another bottleneck so now
you see all this robot are working
slowly okay too slowly for the industry
they say okay I want it is good but at
least can it do the things at the human
pace at human speed Okay, if not so the
the industry will not bite, okay, to be
honest. So you have to do like demos but
uh or or controllers that works at least
at the human speed and human pace. Um
and of course last but not least uh if
you develop a humanoid technology
without having a digital twin like
nearby or a management system that can
allocate the task for this humanoid
robot. So it will be extremely hard to
deploy it. So in the case of Airbus they
have of course if you take this robot
whether even if it's really reliable and
good at 100% if you cannot connect it to
any digital twin or to management who
can allocate the task automatic
automatically uh it will not going to
fly okay so that's why I think that uh
what industry likes also wants and part
of the requirements is to have a turnkey
solution to integrate human into the
manufacturing
so safety is also something that not
many people looked at okay But in
industry you cannot and even at houses
you will not bring any technology
without safety and the safety is not
just a matter of software okay it's all
first of all a matter of hardware you
have to build a smart hardware okay that
and with sensing and all the things that
make your robot safe okay in all cases
safe means that it's safe for the human
workers it's safe for the environment so
in airbas for instance let me okay if
your robot fall and it will touch the
fusage and then it destroy the fus leage
it's 200k for me reparation Okay, if
your robot goes down in the on the
stairs, it's falling, there is a worker
there. How do you guarantee that your
robot will not harm the workers? So
these problems are really important and
they are of the heart of if you want to
deploy this technology to in terms of
things to solve. So there is also one of
the things we we were speaking about is
so you can integrate really cheap
sensing. Now tactile and capacitive are
really there is really cheap solutions
that you can cover all your robot with.
Also there is no reason why the cover of
the robot is rigid. This is a heritage
of uh of automation robots like Faluk
etc. So I have spoken since years to
okay this robot now there is there is no
reason why they need to have a cover
which is rigid okay and it will make it
softer and it will make it safer okay if
it fails etc. So we work also a lot on
on how we can design the robot with soft
cover and soft structures also uh inside
an inner bone of course but uh at the
upper part or the outer part there is no
reason why your robot should be rigid.
So there is also a lot of discussion
about whether we embed the batteries and
the compute. Okay. And uh for me uh the
batteries after talking with industries
they don't need to have really long
time. Okay. So people spend a lot of
time of doing batteries that that stands
long but in fact you don't need it. Uh
obviously if the robot needs how know
how to plug itself there is wires
basically everywhere in Airbus Mishla
and in all the case even in the houses
the robot can't just take this and plug
it if he knows of your robot knows how
to plug itself then the problem is
basically solved in indoor of course if
you are targeting military applications
that's another story okay it's the same
for the compute now 6G will be gamecher
basically and uh there is no reason why
to embed okay a lot of compute in your
robot you can have in a factory the
computer that is localized somewhere
okay and then communicate with your
robot through 6G or through the
networking so basically you need a
minimum setup this makes your robot
already safe uh not very expensive okay
and something that it's practically can
be deployed
um the modality is also an important
point uh so this I discovered also in
industry so you there is no reason also
why you build a human robot with fixed
hands fixed head fixed feet okay um
there is uh there is uh in Airbus mini
most of the cases the workers have hands
to grab tools okay they don't grab
something else sometimes you need hands
if you want to assemble things this but
in most of the cases I see the workers
will take tools so if you know if you
want if you know how to change tools
very quickly heads also and also the uh
even the the the the part this is what
we are doing with shuffler now I advise
shuffler to to design new one that are
extremely modular so that you can change
the base for the locomotion you can
change also the arm you can change uh
many things but you need to design okay
a system for changing mechanism that can
that can stand okay the mechanical
stress robustness change on the fly okay
uh without the need of turning off your
robot for instance uh to automate
updates of the field bus which is not
easy with the uh with all the field
buses to make them uh to update them of
course uh to automate of course the
control and the policy without the need
of learning again and uh no full
retraining or programming this is also
very important.
So the challenge now what I have from
industries is basically is how can I
program my robot without having someone
dedicated to that. Okay. And this is
where AI is bringing a lot of things uh
here like you you show what the robot
has to do from a video and then you are
able to play it right on the fly. So we
have good results on that that are being
patent now and uh we have standing a
paper that will go into it because we do
it differently. We don't generate
blackbox policies. So we use AI but to
generate codes that are explainable.
Okay. And that can program your robot on
the fly. Um of course local manipulation
skill is one of the things which is hard
to to train because you need to train a
robot to walk and to manipulate
together. So you need like a technology
which is uh able to do that. And of
course the third point which is not uh
which is not which is important as well
is to be sure you can make sustainable
and eco-friendly hardware software.
Okay. Um so this is some concluding
remarks uh because many people are right
now now they show deos okay which is on
YouTube cycles and they work a lot on
the AI and the compute and the digits
okay but this is a long way to go to
robots like okay who can do 1 million
cycle because if you bring your robot
okay to industries you really need okay
to have uh more than a million or 200k K
cycles where your humanoid robot is
doing the job without uh of course
failures and this is not a matter of
bites okay this is a matter of atoms and
molecules
Japan if you unblock your robot okay if
you say my robot is made in France or
made in China I would like to know where
are made the components okay because the
Japanese have worked a lot spend a lot
of time to know okay what is the right
material material okay for my gearbox or
for the for the flex of your gearbox
okay and they are able to process uh
like a steel which has zero default and
this is about the process it's not about
these things even China cannot reverse
engineer it they have spent years to
know what is the best lubricant okay
that will allow you to have the cycles
okay and this is a matter of atoms and
molecules not a matter of bites thank
you for listening and this is just the
sponsors for for for the So,